và đồng văn thư giới cho biết trong quy ba năm 2018,
nhưng không chào nằm tổng như cầu văn quan cầu đã tăng má phần chăm
sau với cùng kiến nơi ngoại, đã thân một nghiên bà chăm tấn.
Đây là mất cao nhất tính theo hối lượng,
kể từ khi uổi đồng văn thư giới bắt đầu thung kê trong hàng năm qua,
chú yếu giòn giới đầu từ tìm kiểm cân chua an thuàn,
giữa các cạnh địa chính trị và bến đồng cình tế thuần cầu.
Kéo hội đồng văn thư giới như cầu văn tính theo giá chị,
tăng bống mít thư phần chăm,
đa một trong bống mít sống tì đồ là mỹ trong quy ba.
Giờ phàng, này đã lên tới bống nghiên bà chăm tạm với một đồ là mỹ một AUS,
vào tháng người, mất cao nhất mọi thời đại,
trước khi giảm, giòn hợp đậu chút lời.
Giờ phần tính nhận định giữ lòng ngày về nguy cơ chính phủ mỹ đón cơ,
và khả năng cộp dự chữ li bằng Mỹ Fat Tip tục các giảm hơi sốt,
đã có phần dưới chi sức hấp sống của văn trong những tháng vừa qua.